Thanksgiving, if it weren't for the importance
of Christmas, it would be my favorite holiday.
It's wonderful, and for deep reasons in my
opinion.
Thanksgiving comes in the autumn and comes
when the harvest is in.
The thing that you harvest grows of its own
accord.
You can't make that happen.
There was this movement that the nation should
be grateful and atone at the end of each harvest,
each productive year.
You have to remember, until the middle of
the 20th century, most everybody was a farmer.
Those things that I just said were in the
bones of everybody.
The nation should be grateful.
Isn't that lovely?
Freedom is a blessing.
Learning is a blessing.
Constitutional government is a blessing.
We should be apologetic.
We should be regretful when we fail to count
those blessing and live up to them.
We should say so to God and we should thank
him for the existence of those blessings and
our chance to pursue them.
Not bad for Thanksgiving.